[Music]
well new at noon a new addition to the
las vegas strip the south part of the
las vegas strip mary jane balieza with a
groundbreaking ceremony for the dream
hotel and what tourists can expect
construction is set to begin on a new
hotel and casino the dream hotel will be
located right next to the las vegas sign
in a groundbreaking ceremony friday
morning community leaders like governor
steve sisselak and clark county
commissioner jim gibson were in
attendance for opening remarks and to
congratulate those working on this
project bill shopoff is the president of
shop off realty investments he says his
company purchased the land last year
with project costs at 550 million
dollars cobit actually never slowed us
down we had to work with the airport
authority and allay their concerns and
anxieties and they were great to work
with and we really appreciated actually
commissioner gibson was a was a star and
provided great leadership to help us
navigate through that process with 531
rooms the new hotel will feature eight
different food and beverage options a
day club pool and a casino senior vice
president of mccarthy building companies
ross edwards says he is excited to bring
jobs to the las vegas valley we're
adding about 1200 new construction jobs
plus an additional 2 000
jobs related to the project that are off
site
so it's a it's going to be great for the
community and we're super excited to be
working on it's going to be a new
landmark in las vegas the proposed
opening date for the dream hotel and
casino is late 20-24 reporting from the
strip mary jane balleza live local now